English is a worldwide language and if
you want to live function and thrive in
this globalized world you have to be
able to speak it fluently so one might
conclude that everybody native English
speakers in non-native English speakers
consider English to be an indispensable
useful efficient tool to make
communication in general much easier but
the reality is there are some people who
are not that satisfied about English
having this worldwide status for a
number of reasons and they may have a
point
hi my name is Luca from Lucca Lampard
comm and today we're going to explore
whether English is actually getting in
the way of learning other foreign
languages let's start by exploring and
taking a look at some of the
disadvantages or obstacles that people
might have when it comes to practicing
learning foreign languages and let's
start with the perspective of native
English speakers within the group of
native English speakers Australians
Americans Brits there is a group that
never leaves the country and who will
always live in their original country
for most native English speakers who
never move abroad while learning a
foreign language is not that important
even if they have to deal with tourists
coming to their own country well they do
it in their own native language because
they expect everybody to speak English
so living in your own country never
moving abroad and on top of that having
English as your mother tongue well most
often than not it keeps you from even
starting learning foreign languages so
let's consider native English speakers
who actually move abroad and live abroad
for a long period of time well for a lot
of them speaking a foreign language is
not an option because first they think
that learning the local language is too
difficult and second people local people
might speak English and third they live
within the so called expats bubble which
allows them to speak English all the
time without necessarily resorting to
the local language or any other language
for that
matter so living in their own country
where everybody speaks English possibly
having to do with tourists who speak
their own language and not really having
to learn other foreign languages if not
at school
bits and pieces of French Spanish German
or whatnot well that's the perfect
combination for I don't really need to
speak other languages okay now we've
taken a look at the lazy categories of
native English speakers but what about
the native English speakers who actually
do want to learn a foreign language be
it because they're really interested in
and they live in their own country or
because they move abroad and they really
want to blend in they really want to
integrate in the local life in this case
even if a native English speaker has an
ironclad will to speak their local
language well all sorts of things can
actually happen that do not depend on
them let's consider mark an American guy
living in New York who suddenly decides
to move to the Netherlands after
learning Dutch for two years he goes
there tries to interact with native
speakers he's really willing to use
Dutch as much as he can and much to his
dismay he actually finds out that most
of the time Dutch people tend to reply
to him in English as you know in Sweden
a Norway or the Netherlands for that
matter people speak so well speak
English so well that they tend to use it
and actually think they're doing you a
favor by switching back to English maybe
because you're Dutch you're in a region
or you're Swedish is not still that good
so in this case English does get a
little bit in the way be it because your
level in the foreign language you're
trying to practice is not good enough or
because the English of the local people
is actually too good and the funny thing
is that this does not only happen with
locals who master English and speak
English extremely well this actually
happens to native English speakers who
try to practice a local language with
locals who want to practice their
English because their English is not
good enough so the fact that English is
a worldwide language and everybody
speaks it or wants to speak it sometimes
gets in the way of you learning a
foreign language
and let's consider one final category
there's actually a lot more categories
but we're just considering the main ones
that is none native English speakers who
want to practice the target language
what happens then
well again a lot of things can happen
they can talk to a local person they
meet in a shop on the market wherever
and this person happens to want to speak
and practice English or their level is
not good enough they don't feel
confident maybe they're a little bit
tired or they're just lazy and they tend
to resort to English by myself and I
will tell you in a second about my
personal story and guilty sometimes of
resorting to English and I'm not doing
the right thing and we're doing the easy
thing just because I am lazy so let's
take Mario a guy from Rome who decides
to move to Greece and he wants to
practice Greek as much as he can again a
number of things can happen let's
suppose that mario meets a person on the
market and speaks greek and that person
replies in english because he wants to
practice english or let's suppose that
mario wants to take lessons on skype for
example and he wants to practice greek
sometimes it happens that mario is a
little bit lazy he might be a little bit
tired and he himself resource to english
or a Studer maybe thinks that his level
of greek is not good enough and he
speaks english constantly trying to
explain greek patterns and greek
grammars and whatnot so there's a wide
range of reasons that depend on you that
depend on the situation that depend on
the person you were talking about for
which unfortunately English kind of gets
in the way of learning foreign languages
so mark on the one hand and Mari on the
other are just two very simple examples
of what can happen and how English can
actually get in the way of learning
foreign languages unfortunately we do
not have time to explore all the
possible situations but this was just to
give you an idea of what can happen to
you and what can happen to me or anybody
else for that matter when it comes to
learning and practicing foreign
languages
so you might think that English is that
kind of bully that gets into the picture
you're taking a picture for yourself and
this guy pops up it hey I'm there I'm
always there but the reality is that
it's not all doom and gloom as they say
in fact having English around as a
lingua franca has a lot of benefits so
let's meet Francois a Parisian who
decides to move to China he doesn't
speak a word of Chinese when he lives in
China he meets a very interesting
Chinese girl who does not speak a word
of French but they both speak English so
they can actually start communicating in
English and then later they can learn
each other's language that has happened
so many times across the world and it's
a great benefit and it's a great
blessing to have a language through
which you can immediately communicate
another benefit of having English as a
lingua franca and this is especially for
language buffs like me is that language
learning material for rarer languages is
most often than not just in English so
you can leverage the knowledge that you
have in English or any other lingua
franca like French or Russian to learn
other languages that you would not be
able to learn if you just didn't speak
English English is also very very
beneficial when it comes to using
translation in order to learn a foreign
language you can translate back and
forth you can compare structures with
the target language between the target
language and the English language and
there's a lot of learning materials that
have English on the one side and the
target language on the other side
English is also very fast and efficient
too when it comes to extracting
information from your language tutor or
language partner the person you were
talking to but suppose that you are
Italian and you're learning Greek and
you're talking to your Greek tutor and
you don't know how to say something well
you just ask how do you say this in
Greek and you say this in English and
the other person very often speaks
English well and can immediately deliver
the answer that's a very fast way of
communicating and filling in the gaps by
using English on and off of course some
purists say that it would be better to
stick to just to the target language and
that is obviously preferred
but I don't think that that is a
disadvantage another example of how
English can be beneficial is that I for
one and making this video exactly in
English some of you sometimes complain
that I should make more videos in other
languages truth be told but making these
videos in English easily allows me to
reach a very very wide audience and talk
practically to everyone my personal take
on this is that English is neither bad
or good and I always tend to use an ends
logic more than an or logic I think that
it's great to use English and other
languages it's not English or other
languages sometimes I myself will decide
to use English a little bit more
sometimes my interlocutor will reply in
English it does not matter this still
hasn't kept me from using all the
languages that I've been learning in the
ears and I think that it all boils down
to attitude and decisions if sometimes
someone replies you in English you can
gently say look I've been learning this
language Dutch be a Dutch Greek or any
other language for some time and it will
really practice it sometimes it just
boils down to conveying the message and
just telling your interlocutor this is
what I really want to do it can do
wonders
referring to what I said before about
the disadvantages and/or advantages of
using English as a lingua franca a lot
of times English has gotten a little bit
in the way for example I myself am
guilty sometimes of resorting to English
when I'm not confident enough in the
foreign language or when I'm too tired
or again when I'm lazy be it in
conversations on skype or in real life
surprisingly in a lot of circumstances
in countries I do not like speaking the
local language in shops or in brief
interactions when I have to buy
something at the supermarket and the
local shop etc I don't really know why
but I do remember that I was in Poland I
was with Richard Simpkins many of you I
know Richard Simchat he's a fantastic
polyglot and once I just kept using
English while the main goal of being in
Poland was actually speaking polish and
he looked at me and said we've got is
there a problem with this and I said no
there's no problem it's just that I
don't find these short interactions very
meaningful while for him that was that
made his day interacting with these
people he that's reason why he went
there he ate there because he wanted to
practice the language also in these
situations and this also happens when I
have conversations in Hungarian or Greek
languages I'm actively learning
languages I'm eager to speak as much as
I can with my tutors sometimes I resort
to English to explain things that are
really difficult or sometimes I don't
have a word and I asked directly in
English so I would say that Oh in all
having English in my life has been a
great benefit I've never read it
speaking English and to this day I
really like speaking it be it with
non-native or a native English speakers
it has never kept me from learning other
languages it actually helped me learn
other languages and sometimes I have to
accept that you know using English when
you're a little bit too tired not
confident and whatnot is absolutely
natural again it all boils down to
- and now a couple of questions for you
how has English impacted you language
learning is English your native language
or a foreign language how have you used
English to learn foreign languages
have you ever stumbled upon people are
really proud and really stubborn about
speaking English instead of letting you
practice language you want to practice
please feel free to share all your
experiences all your methods in the
comment section below I will take some
of the comments I will read them out
loud and I will reply in a video once
again thanks a lot for watching and see
you very very soon here on YouTube
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]